so
[Music]
this imminent movement proclaims the
absolute being is spirit absolute being
that is not grasped as spirit is merely
the abstract void just as spirit that is
not grasped as this movement is only an
empty word
when its moments are grasped in their
purity they are the restless notions
which only are in being in themselves
their own opposite and in finding their
rest in the whole
but the picture thinking of the
religious community is not this
speculative thinking it has the content
but without its necessity and instead of
the the form of the notion it brings
into the realm of pure consciousness the
natural relationships of father and son
since this consciousness even in its
thinking remains at the level of picture
thinking absolute being is indeed
revealed to it but the moments of this
being on account of all this empirically
synthetic presentation partly themselves
fall asunder so that they are not
related to one another through their own
notion and partly this consciousness
retreats from this its pure object
relating itself to it only in an
external manner
the object is revealed to it by
something alien and it does not
recognize itself in this thought of
spirit does not recognize the nature of
pure self-consciousness
insofar as the form of picture thinking
and of those relationships derived from
nature must be transcended and
especially also the standpoint which
takes the moments of the movement which
spirit is is isolated and movable
substances or subjects instead of
transient moments the transcending of
this standpoint is to be regarded as a
compulsion on the part of the notion as
we pointed out earlier
in connection with another aspect
but since this compulsion is instinctive
self-consciousness misunderstands its
own nature rejects the content as well
as the form and what amounts to the same
thing degrades the content into
historical pictorial idea into an
heirloom handed down by tradition
in this way it is only the purely
external element in belief that is
retained and as something therefore that
is dead and cannot be known but the
inner element in faith has vanished
because this would be the notion that
knows itself as notion
paragraph
771 is getting a little bit more
concrete although there's still a lot of
abstraction here of course but you start
to get a better picture of where the
preceding paragraphs were going you know
hegel loves this notion of a circular
movement and seeing everything
in the totality and that is indeed the
way that that spirit and the
let's call it the most adequate
self-understanding of spirit through
concept or notion but grief takes place
and religion by its
very nature
is
not all that conceptual in hegel's sense
and much more rooted
in lower forms of cognition that are not
able to grasp themselves entirely as
such lower forms and for stellang which
we've been talking about throughout this
entire section really throughout the
entire religion section is is the
determinate way in which this takes
place and we're talking here about the
foreshadowing or the picture thinking
representation pictorial presentation is
another translation that's being used
here of the
religious community the the gemini um so
this is um
you know a very important paragraph for
developing a
let's call it
dilemma that has to be faced a
fork in the road
where inadequacy is realized and
spirits or the you know religious person
or the community can go one way or can
go the other or can you know maybe a
trilemma it can remain
in place and that's what we see taking
place here on the part of consciousness
or self-consciousness
it's either going to remain rooted in
picture thinking or it's going to
descend to something even lesser than
picture thinking
or it's going to ascend to the notion
and obviously which
which are we supposed to choose which is
which way is religion supposed to go
it's supposed to go for the notion and
in this case hagel says some very
interesting things we not only have the
notion we have
absolute being a spirit and it's
its moments are
notions so that's one side we also at
the very end have the notion that knows
itself as notion we could call it notion
squared if you want to although it you
know this is part of what it means to be
notional or conception
conceptual right is that there is a
grasping of
one's own involvement in the very
activity that's going on it's not just
treating everything as a object at
gagenstand
but there's a totality that includes the
knower right
so all that said
let's see what hegel is actually saying
in the text
he begins by saying this imminent
movement what's the imminent movement
well what we just talked about in
paragraph 769 and 770 right in 770 he
said there's three distinct moments
essence and two kinds of being for self
and all of these are the three moments
uh that are involved in this kaisenda
uh bevagoing the circular movement right
so this imminent movement that we're
talking about here proclaims
absolute being veisin as spirit
geist
what we've been
charting out the entire time what we're
working with right
geist is sort of you know
not the raw material as such but the raw
material and the shaper and the knower
and we can keep going on and on and on i
mean this is the phenomenology of geist
of spirit
so
what does this mean harry says two
really interesting things that we're
probably gonna have to come back to a
little bit later
absolute being
that is not grasped
as right and then
spirit that is not grasped as and there
there's you know one of these is in as
this movement right and if you're not
grasping if you're not conceptualizing
these two things absolute being and
spirit
they cease being what they
are
why well
absolute being
that is not grasped as spirit
so it's grasped in another way
is merely the abstract void
the era right an emptiness
something that we think
is going to provide us with plentitude
and explanations and satisfaction and it
turns out not to do so this is what
happened in the unhappy consciousness
and this is also you could say what
happened in the
faith and insight section as well and
this is what's happening in previous
forms of consciousness that are also
religious
if we're not grasping absolute being the
the god the deity the divinity as spirit
in this sort of complex
uh interconnected way
well then we're going to sooner or later
exhaust the resources of that point of
view
and we may not realize that in any one
given author or ritual or community or
generation but sooner or later people
will
come to see the inadequacies of that
that perspective right
what about spirit
this is very interesting and this should
give a lot of people pause
when you talk about hegel if you don't
actually know
what the hell you're talking about if
you haven't done the work of traversing
this long path of spirit in the
phenomenology hegel would say if you if
you're taking shortcuts
you're not really talking about spirit
anymore you're
reducing spirit to a linguistic
expression
so how does he say this he says spirit
not grasp to this movement is only an
empty
word now he's just talked about the word
in several paragraphs earlier so if
we're thinking about this in terms of
like well jesus christ is spirit in
christianity
if you don't really think these things
through all the way hegel's saying
you're just playing around with empty
signifiers it's fun to do you can hang
out with all your you know friends
whether online or in hegel groups or
something like that and chitter chatter
about this sort of thing
but you're not really getting
what he's saying and you know this is a
bit of a
let's call this a rant on my part right
a lot of people read the phenomenology
and they you know they read the preface
they usually skip over the introduction
because the preface is so much cooler
and they you know get through the the
consciousness section and they're mostly
interested in you know uh the very first
part of it and the very end part of it
right so they're interested in the sense
perception right and and uh the
consciousness of that
um and then they're interested in the
you know force and the understanding and
they don't spend the time to actually
understand it then they want to get to
the the really cool stuff the master
slave dialectic which means reading the
you know the first part the truth of
self-certainty and then they kind of you
know skim through the stoicism
skepticism unhappy consciousness even
though that's bigger and then they get
to the you know the reason section and
the spirit section which are the biggest
parts of the book right that's the bulk
of the phenomenology
and they you know they touch here and
there on things well you know we should
talk about the beautiful soul in the
spirit section and we definitely should
talk about the phrenology and
physiognomy section because it's got
that cool quote spirit is a bone which
hegel is saying spirit is not a bone you
should punch people out who actually
think that but they miss all that and
then they get to this this section and
they're talking about spirit and hegel
would say you you don't know
what you're talking about because you
haven't done the
rigorous work of getting through all of
this stuff all right rant over
caution over
let's let's jump into the what he says
here so
it says when its moments are grasped in
their purity
what moments
absolute being is spirit they are
restless notions
which only are and here we get the
typical hegelian thing right being in
their themselves their own opposite
that's you know okay that's typical
hegel things generate their own
opposition but he says finding their
rest the rua in in the hole in the
totality the totality right the gun
sights right so
this is important these these moments
these notions they are connected with
each other
and
they find their meaning their total
meaning in a whole that they comprise
that whole includes us
if we're religious believers it includes
us it includes the community
right and it includes this entire
process
so he goes on and he says
the picture thinking of the religious
community is not this speculative
thinking
it is thinking it is denkin right so we
have thinking at all three of these
levels but the
thinking is thinking is happening in
terms of this speculative perspective
this
you know
perspective that takes in
all of what's what's happening here
including the failed approaches as well
and understands why these are failing
approaches so
what is the picture thinking of the
religious community
so he says it has the content without
its necessity
we're going to come back to that and
instead of the form of the notion the
concept the grief
it brings into the realm of pure
consciousness
the natural relationships
right the natural interconnections the
being related to each other
of father and son
a little bit later
the way it'll be translated is these are
relationships derived from nature
we'll talk about that in just a moment
to what degree are they really truly
derived
from
nature or do they involve
culture humanity
in a certain way as well but the the key
thing here
is that consciousness the consciousness
of the religious community which is also
self-consciousness
is grasping
the absolute being of spirit through the
these models these
images of natural relationships and that
is what hegel calls picture thinking for
stellang
he's also going to call this
a synthetic presentation
presentation translated here by miller
is just for stellam so a sin you know
synthetic
uh it's it's still picture thinking uh
presentation collective imagination
however you want to
understand it and notice the word
synthetic here
so
again you know i've said this so many
times hegel is not about
uh thesis antithesis greater synthesis
here something being synthetic
is actually a sign of it not being the
final thing synthetic here could be
opposed to
conceptual
flicker right or greifen
so
but it's also opposed to this this sort
of rejection of content and form that's
going to take place in just a moment as
well
so he says
it remains at the level of picture
thinking absolute being is indeed
revealed to it we have revealed religion
right open borrowing
it's revealed to it
but
the moments of this being
on account of this synthetic
presentation
partly themselves fall asunder so
they're not related to one another
now
they are related to one another because
we have a relationship here
but they're not related to each other
how are they not related to each other
through the concept they are related to
each other through picture thinking
which does place them as if they are
separate things immovable uh substances
or subjects so the you know i mean we
can talk about the trinity and and you
know how complex that is all we want and
you know the father is not the son but
the both of them are god right
and then we bring in the holy spirit to
make it even more complicated but just
just like father and son for a while and
also think to yourself you know uh is
hegel on the right track here i mean
if you think about some of the
conceptual problems
that early christians got into and then
got into arguments about and then split
into different communities about think
about the aryans right the aryans uh you
know
father son
they can't really be equal what's this
jesus guy about he is he's the son in a
metaphorical sense you know he's a
really awesome guy and teacher and stuff
like that but he's not begotten by the
father
you know
that would be sort of a rejection of
natural relationship is adequate it's
not yet conceptual in arianism
it's actually closer to this
you could call it falling away or bad
alternative for self-consciousness the
self-consciousness of the community and
we could go on and on with other
interesting examples
so let's come back to this right
um and actually let's pause on this for
a moment before we start talking about
you know this external manner and all
that
is the relationship between father and
son
a relationship purely of nature
or is there in fact
cultural
components to it experiential components
i'm reminded of a guy who i knew when i
was working at indiana state prison and
teaching in a religious studies classes
and he was teaching for a different
college i was teaching for ball state
university he was teaching for grace
college and we're having lunch and he
was talking about fatherhood
and
the difficulty in talking about god as
the father if your father was a complete
a-hole you know as was the case for many
of these guys
in lock-up
you know they would see that and they'd
be like well why would i want to relate
myself to somebody who abused me who
abandoned me who exploited me who did
all these terrible things not just to me
but also to my siblings and to my mother
you know why would i why would i want to
conceive god in that way or if god is
that way then i guess god is a big jerk
as well you know
that's not a natural relationship
or natural understanding of fatherhood
that is something that's coming from
experience that's something that's also
racinated in culture how should a father
be this varies from culture to culture
to culture what are the duties incumbent
upon a son how does generationality and
inheritance work
these are not purely natural relations
right so and what am i saying here is
hegel wrong is he playing fast and loose
with you no no um but these are these
are um
pictured
or imagined or represented relations are
they not and this this there's another
really interesting implication here that
hegel doesn't draw out
what if we reconceptualize god what if
we say oh god's not a father god's a
mother
and we you know re-gender the
parent and you know the mother and the
daughter let's make it like that or you
know god is non-binary um
we're still working in the realm of
representation here we're still working
with if not you know purely natural
relationships certainly conditioned
cultural relationships that are probably
not adequate to what the divinity is
so we don't get out of it just by saying
oh i'll get rid we'll get past father
and son
that's the big problem there i mean as a
matter of fact uh you know you want to
see a great christian thinker who
conceptualizes god both as father and as
mother and discusses this look at saint
anselm you know uh read the monologian
read some of his letters read other
places where he's talking about this his
prayers and meditations where he uh
effectively re-genders you know saint
paul as a mother you know uh so you know
we go on and on with this let's come
back to the hegel at this point so he
says
they're not related to one another
through their own notion and this
consciousness retreats from this it's
pure object relating itself to it only
in an external manner this is you know
foreshadowing the descent the fall we
could say he says the sp the object is
revealed to it by something alien
and it does not recognize itself in this
thought of spirit so it's missing things
on two sides right
the object is revealed to it by
something alien which is picture
thinking
an externalization a descent into
otherness as we've seen in previous
paragraphs and that
obscures the object itself
and it obscures consciousness or
self-consciousness his own involvement
in this it doesn't see a place
for itself in the father and the son
right
so what happens then
he says
insofar as the form of picture thinking
and of those relationships derived from
nature must be
transcended
right we have to go up right
we have to go outside of this
and especially also the standpoint which
takes the moments of the movement which
spirit is
as isolated and movable substances or
subjects instead of
correctly seeing them as transient
moments the transcending of this
standpoint is to be regarded as a
compulsion
on the part of the notion
now isn't that an interesting
way to talk about it and hegel tells us
i've you know pointed this out earlier
in connection with another aspect
yes but he didn't use the same term
compulsion
right a drive
this is part of the notion itself the
notion as alive the notion ascension the
notion as involving us taking us along
for the ride and saying come on we got
to go over here and do something
and what do we do with it what does the
religious community what does the
religious believer do with it well they
either ascend or they
descend and they screw things up
right
and then they can oscillate between this
picture thinking and an even more
ineffective inadequate historical
pictorial idea which is another kind of
picture thinking right so what he says
is
this is a compulsion on the part of the
notion but since this compulsion is
instinctive and he uses the word
instinct there right
this compulsion
isn't really
adequately
self-conscious
or conscious of the demands of its
object
it's forgotten things along the way what
happens
well there's a rejection
of both the form and the content right
the form is inadequate but it doesn't
reject the form of picture thinking
altogether it generates a new kind of
picture thinking
and this is interesting because what is
hegel
targeting here
well uh two things right two things that
we would have a tendency to
blur together
but he's actually got two different
targets in mind
well let's read what the text says and
then we'll you know talk about the
diagram a little bit more so
um self-consciousness misunderstands its
own nature and rejects the content as
well as the form and what amounts to the
same thing degrades
the content so it's rejecting the form
but still using the form it degrades the
content to two things
a historical pictorial idea
which is a foreshadowing but now it's a
geschica for shaolin and remember back
in the previous paragraphs where what is
it that the
um picture thinking actually comes to
you know realize itself realize is going
on in here
the happening gashen right
gashayan and geschicht are connected
with each other so you know
what is what are what are the happenings
right a historical pictorial idea
hegel is actually i think here
criticizing some of the higher criticism
the higher biblical criticism that is
taking aim at the
the revelation and the way that the
revelation has been typically understood
by the community and saying well you
know you can't actually trust all these
gospel narratives you know we need to
reconsider
this part and this part and you know you
cut out enough stuff and and you really
don't have much of a
story at all right
or it's an heirloom handed down by
tradition
and what is why why is uh miller saying
handed down by tradition because
tradition itself means handing down that
is what it is traditional right and so
we could easily lose this as english
speakers the very current of tradition
is the handing of things down from
generation to generation so we have the
dry historical desiccated external idea
or we have something that's being handed
down by tradition rather uncritically
rather blindly
none of these are a great alternative to
the picture thinking that's already
going on here right none of these are a
transcending although they may purport
to be a transcending so
what's the transcending that we're
supposed to be
aiming at
well he tells us right um
there we go
well i mean let's go back to the start
right absolute being
as spirit and grasping the restless
notions which are in being themselves
their own opposite finding their rest in
the whole that's where we're supposed to
be going and if you look at the very end
of this
um you know
the notion that knows itself as notion
which would be is what we're aiming at
right the inner element in faith uh
disappearing that way so he goes on and
he says um
in this way only the purely external
element and belief is retained something
that is dead and cannot be known the
inner element in faith has vanished
where would we get the inner element in
faith
by
grasping
the religious object and ourselves
as spirits
as together through the notion
through the notion that knows itself as
notion
which is where we're going in the
following paragraphs which is what we're
aiming for
this entire time we don't yet have it
completely right but we're we're getting
further we're and we're not totally
leaving this other stuff behind as you
know this is just rejected crap you know
we're not pulling the ladder up with us
this all still matters and actually
generationally people will probably need
to pass through this every generation if
what hegel is viewing as the consummate
religion is is to continue on but for
hegel for hegel this is his vision of
christianity
we need to move to this we can't rely
just on picture thinking any more than
we can on historical picture thinking or
a tradition that would be handing you
know essentially picture thinkings on
that people have actually lost the the
meaning of over time and notice that
this is also here's where i want to wrap
up also a compulsion you know hegel
talked about the uh compulsion of
of spirit right or the compulsion of the
notion the dangan
it can go one of two ways and in a
certain respect we can say
we have a choice about where we're going
in the phenomenology obviously hegel's
telling us
go here don't go here because other
people are already going here and that's
a dead end so we're going to follow out
where he's going in taking the path of
the notion
or the concept
you